jason what's up i'm about to move to a
new city that's roughly three hours
two or three hours away uh and while i'm
excited about starting a new job and
going to a new place and moving out of
my parents house for the first time
away from my hometown i'm also nervous
about it
um and uh basically i'm just looking for
advice on uh you know how to kind of
re-establish
uh community friendships uh
stuff like that uh basically i'm moving
away to start a new job
how old are you man i'm 27.
what yeah
jason you're 27 asking me how to move
out of your mom's house
come on man yeah come on man
why are you still living at your mom's
house at 27
well so basically i had a full-time job
but i didn't really feel comfortable
moving in with roommates or um
things like that why not why not why not
well i think i think it was just because
of the security
of it in a way uh that i've enjoyed
and um so hey we gotta drill down in
this man i'm sorry to interrupt you
so you're dead you had a full-time job
you're doing grown-up things
but you liked the security of your mom's
house
to the point that you didn't want to
have roommates you didn't want to
split the rent you didn't even want to
have your own apartment so when you say
you liked the security of your mom's
house is that warm meals does she tuck
you in did she sing to you at night like
what what do you mean
you like the security no i think it was
just a thing of like
i i feel like i have trust issues with
other folks and um where does that come
from
in all honesty i feel like i don't
necessarily
know per se um
yeah um
is your mom does your mom love having
you at home
she does yeah is your dad there too
uh he is yeah what is he does he love
having you live at home
as an almost 30 year old man or is he
just muttering around the house
just shuffling his feet in his slippers
just going oh i borrowed that boy that
boy
or does he just kind of kind of the
ladder kind of the ladder yeah
okay and was your mom somebody who
was overly involved in your life is this
new
yeah i mean i would say my mom and i
were definitely closer than me and my
dad
for sure so
i mean if you're almost 30 just now
moving out for the first
time yeah i mean i guess i can see
that this is going to be weird for you
um
yeah i mean i'm excited about it it's
just
i'm nervous about it to a whole new
level you know what what
what led you to finally cut the
umbilical cord and take a job
three hours away yeah um
well you know it's one of those things
where i felt like when i woke up on my
birthday this past year
i just realized i didn't want to be
seven years old
yeah yeah like and i don't want to be
living at my parents house forever
you know uh especially when i have like
friends of mine that have moved on with
their lives and
like i just i didn't want to be that guy
you know okay so
people call my show for a hard truth
brother so i'm just telling you
you super are that guy you already are
okay now you can work to become unthat
guy but right now i
am just telling you you are that guy
yeah
so until you've lived in another city
um or in another house in another one
bedroom apartment for a year
you're that guy okay yeah and so
you woke up one day you're on your 27th
birthday and you just had this like what
am i doing
and you started applying for jobs you
got a job three hours away what field do
you work in
so i work in uh process management i
don't even know what that means but it
sounds like you manage processes so
that's good
and you're going three hours away have
you already got an apartment you already
got a house
yeah uh actually uh what's what's funny
is i actually
uh just moved uh the other day yeah oh
so you're here all by yourself
and your big boy house yeah yeah i've
i've hit the ground here so
okay so jason like how have you been
sleeping and i'm not making i'm not
making fun i'm being serious have you
been sleeping
yeah so um i i feel like i've been
sleeping well
um i think it's one of those things
where it's like the excitement of it has
kind of hit
but also it's just one of those things
where i
i i'm nervous about you know rebuilding
community with friends that i know here
and stuff like that so yeah
so um
i'm gonna do two different things here
okay number one
okay um i've had my fun at your expense
right and it sounds like you're
good-natured and you get it right that
you're 27 and we're still living with
your mom
you even woke up one day and you're like
dude what am i doing okay so
yeah now everyone listening to this
whether they are mowing the lawn walking
through target somewhere
they are doing whatever it is they're
doing and
they are smiling and or laughing that
there's a guy who's 27 who just moved
out of his mommy's house for the first
time
so there's that okay and then there's
also
part two here which is the very real
fear and nervousness and
so i want to tell you i'm high-fiving
you i'm proud of you for making this
jump
okay and i don't want to minimize the
fact that it is weird it is hard
okay so here's a couple of things that i
had to do recently now i didn't move out
of my mom's house
i i've haven't lived with my parents for
a long time for a couple of decades but
i did leave this a city i'd been in for
years and years and years
and i left friends that i met with every
week
for years and i left places where i knew
the police officers by name i knew city
leaders by name i knew
where the plumber's by name right i knew
all i had a community there
and here's what i had to do i had to be
hyper
hyper intentional about applying
the the true research to my life okay so
here's what the research says jason
all right loneliness will kill you
literally okay
um eating unhealthy will kill you
not moving and not not moving your body
not exercising not sleeping those things
will kill you
okay all of that starts with
intentionality
you have to put yourself in a situation
where you are hyper intentional
about finding friends and connection and
community
that could be through a local church
that could be through
groups with work that could be through
um going up to the ymca and playing
pickup basketball games
there's few people on earth worse at
basketball than me um but
just putting yourself in a situation
where you're going to be around other
people
and here's the thing i need you to
remember i want you to
write this down relationships start with
risk
not with certainty so there is a 100
chance you're gonna ask someone to go
hang out and they're gonna blow you off
and that doesn't mean that you're an
idiot that doesn't mean you're a failure
that means you're just learning
that means that they don't hang out with
you cool and move on to the next and on
to the next and on to the next
relationships start with risk it's
always worth it even if you're on the
other end of the
the negative side of risk right and so
you're going to be hyper intentional
about making community
and that's going to be you saying weird
things like hey man will you be my
friend
and laughing about it um hey man let's
go hang out
once come hang out at my house i'll pick
up the tab
and it's going to be especially hard
during covid
right because some some folks have
different um
abilities to hang out not hang out can
we do it outside
inside heading into winter is going to
be tough you're going to have to be
hyper intentional
and then you're going to have to be
hyper intentional about taking care of
your
your mental health which means you're
going to have to move you're going to
have to eat right you're going to have
to exercise you're going do have to do
all those things
that let you have a good night's sleep
that let you know that you're okay
and then here's um the last thing i
would challenge you on
i would be very intentional about not
calling and or texting my mom every day
yeah i want you to set a weaning off
schedule
okay where you say i'm going to reach
out
i'm going to call once a week and that's
going to push you
to develop relationships in other places
and here's here's something else
it's going to push your mom to have to
develop some different support networks
too
because she's probably leaned on you a
long time
for her own good she's probably
giving you meals way past when she
should have and she's probably
encouraged you just to stay on at home
way
longer than she should have because it
felt
it it it satisfied a need in her and
you're gonna have to let her go develop
relationships too
and expect her to call you and crying i
miss you
i wish you would just come home that's
not on you
that's for her to deal with okay your
responsibility
is not making sure that she has friends
and not making sure that her relational
needs are met
that's her job okay your job is to nobly
respect your mom
um honor her care for her but not to
make sure that um she doesn't cry
that she doesn't that her relational
needs are met i've said that over and
over but
um so have you reached out to somebody
have you hung out with anybody since you
landed in your new town
uh no i haven't okay that's your goal
for this week
got it yeah absolutely that's your goal
for this week is to find somebody to
have lunch with to hang out with
talk to them say hi um
i don't know i don't even know what
you're allowed to do in whatever town
you're in
the things are different all over the
country but some places got movie
theaters that are open people are going
to concerts and comedy shows and
other places it's like um
siberia right you just can't move you
just stay in your house all day and just
walk circles around your couch and so
i don't know what community you're in
but your job this week is to make
connection with somebody
some group of people would probably be
even better and
to start making connection there
have a backup system
that's not your mom have a backup system
that's not
your old bedroom in your old house it's
time for you to go i'm proud of you for
making this call even though i'm going
to poke at you because you're 27.
i'm proud of you for waking up and
realizing oh my gosh i don't want to be
a guy who's at 30 live in his mom's
house
it's a big move man and get some
community take care of yourself